c'était presque un samedi comme les
autres sur la grand place d'arras et ses
alentours
une situation un peu surprenante alors
que les 1 million cinq cent mille
habitants du département du
pas-de-calais ont vécu le premier de
leurs quatre week-ends confiné de quoi
ont laissé certains un peu perplexe
il fait beau donc il ya plein de gens
dehors pourtant des supposés temps
confinement c'est un peu étonnant mais
donc moi j'ai fait mon attestation
normalement on a une heure donc je vais
pas forcément de traîner je suis moi en
colère c'est juste pas possible quoi par
exemple ce matin je me disais moi je
suis vacciné parce que je suis soit
soignante donc j'ai eu cette chance
d'être vacciné très vite et je me dis je
suis obligé de porter le maersk quoi ils
sont obligés d'être confiné alors je
suis vacciné alors donc voila mon
message c'est vaccinez vous vacciner
vous qu'on puisse sortir de tout ça est
le plus vite possible parce que parce
que tout le monde en a mais le pas de
calais est en retard dans la campagne
vaccinale des lenteurs liées à des
contraintes d'approvisionnement avait
d'ailleurs reconnu l' agence régionale
de santé qui assure désormais que ce
retard est comblé tout au long du week
end une campagne coup de poing a été
lancée permettant d'écouler les dix
mille doses débloqués par le ministre de
la santé pour le département ce dimanche
olivier ferrand s'est rendu dans un
centre de vaccination à boulogne-sur-mer
où il a été interpellé par le maire
socialiste de la ville frédéric
cuvillier mais je n'ai pas eu de réponse
définitive et ceux qui m'invite à
poursuivre la demande demande sorte
qu'ils aient d'un celle de permettre le
rattrapage de ce débat dans ce
département et de la région boulonnaise
du nombre de vaccinations faut savoir
que le département du pas-de-calais et
en copine confiné depuis maintenant
quelques jours et le taux de vaccination
étant insuffisant est important que ce
message soit adressée aux autorités
sanitaires c'est à dire de prioriser les
populations qui sont confinés et de leur
permettre d'avoir enfin accès à ces
vaccins qui n'ont que trop tardé une
situation vécue par de nombreux
habitants comme une injustice
c'est vrai qu'à situation sanitaire
équivalente d'autres départements n'ont
pas eu à connaître ses besoins privative
de liberté et que c'est une forme
d'incompréhension doublé par set
ce sentiment d'injustice de ne pas
pouvoir avoir accès à une vaccination
que massive et plus efficace il n'y a
pas de dose caché au ministère a assuré
olivier ferrand qui s'est félicité de
l'effort exceptionnel consenti ce week
end pour accélérer les vaccinations sur
tout le territoire français
actuellement moins de 4 millions de
français ont reçu au moins une dose un
nombre encore très loin de l'objectif
des 10 millions de premières injections
pour la mi-avril